Pt'ain mec, je suis tellement une quiche en drague, moi.
T'as pas des trucs qui marchent à tous les coups, toi ?
Bah moi non.
Mais, par contre...
Bonjour, je m'appelle William, je suis coach en séduction sur Bordeaux et Arcachon.
William a fait une trentaine de vidéos sur sa chaîne youtube avec des conseils excellents
pour amener le plus de filles possible dans son lit.
Avant d'aller aborder les femmes, et bah, bien évidemment il faut avoir pris sa douche.
Mais merci William j'avais totalement oublié ça fait vingt ans que j'ai pas pris de douche putain
Ah oui, ça joue avec les femmes, c'est vrai, maintenant qu'il dit...
Les femmes, elles adorent les chemises,
et si vous mettez comme le font un peu
la plupart des mecs
Juste un t-shirt
Bon sa les femmes, sa les attires pas trop.
juste un t-shirt, bon, ça, les femmes, ça les attire pas trop.
Mettez des belles chemises, et en plus de couleur,
les femmes sont sensibles à tout ce qui est couleur vive,
le jaune, le orange...
Ça, c'est bien vrai.
Quand je croise une femme, à chaque fois que je lui demande,
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ça ?
Elles font : Non, ah non, ah non  j'aime pas... non, le t-... non, pas du...
Aaah, ah, ça, oui, ça, j'aime beaucoup.
Euh, le mauve, couleur vive, je suis attirée vers cette couleur vive,
tel un papillon de nuit vers la lumière.
Il y a plein d'astuces qui marchent à chaque fois,
il faut savoir que William couche avec des dizaines de femmes,
chaque jour.
Sa phrase d'accroche, par exemple.
La phrase d'approche, pour moi, qui est une phrase d'approche
qui est vraiment pas mal.
Vous allez voir, ça marche plutôt très très bien,
il pécho des meufs, comme ça, attention.
Ce serait de dire à la fille :
Bonjour, je m'appelle William j'ai 32 ans je réside à Arcachon je travaille dans l’immobilier et donc je me recherche une copine
Donc, c'est pourquoi j'ai envie de te parler.
Cette phrase...
Je me permets juste d'y mettre un tout petit bémol,
Heuu...
je pense, que si tu t'appelles pas William,
ça ne marche pas trop.
Après, c'est peut-être moi qui suis un peu étriqué d'esprit.
Donc, cette phrase d'approche,
je la répète :
''Bonjour, je m'appelle William...''
Ok, ok, il insiste, ça veut dire que ça marche comme ça.
Il faut la dire comme ça, c'est tout.
Il a aussi de très très bons conseils, très très utiles,
pour les tombeurs séduisants, comme lui.
Je vous dis qu'il faut confirmer tous ses rendez-vous,
au moins 2 heures à l'avance,
parce que si jamais vous faites 30 ou 40 kilomètres
pour aller à ce rendez-vous,
et que la fille n'y est pas,
elle vous aura fait perdre votre temps, de l'argent,
parce que ça fait dépenser de l'essence,
et moralement,
ça sera pas bien.
Alors ça, c'est un conseil pour les autres,
faut savoir que ça lui est jamais arrivé,
lui, il a pas besoin de... mais,
pour vous, juste un SMS, et c'est bon comme ça, au moins, on est sûr.
Alors si elle vous répond "ok,
ça tient pour le rendez-vous",
vous continuez votre truc.
Juste avant de partir, hop,
vous renvoyez un deuxième SMS,
"je suis en train de partir,
est-ce que ça tient toujours pour le rendez-vous ?"
D'accord, c'est vrai, c'est vrai qu'on n'est jamais trop prudent.
Je le rappelle encore une fois, lui, ça lui est jamais arrivé qu'on le plante.
Et ensuite, pendant le trajet,
quand vous êtes à mi-chemin,
vous vous arrêtez sur le bord de la route,
vous envoyez un dernier petit SMS,
en disant :
"Je suis en route, j'arrive bientôt."
Comme ça, ça vous évite de faire 30, 40 kilomètres pour rien.
D'accord ! Oui, oui, c'est vrai que même moi, ce que je fais,
c'est que j'envoie un quatrième SMS aux trois-quarts du parcours
avec mes coordonnées GPS
et mon niveau d'essence, comme ça,
elle sait bien où je suis exactement.
Et je m'arrête là, parce que souvent au cinquième SMS,
elle appelle les flics.
Je vais vous parler de comment draguer en supermarché.
Pourquoi draguer une fille dans un quelconque bar
où elle passe du bon temps nul, comme ça,
alors qu'on peut l'aborder pendant qu'elle achète
ses tampons 5 gouttes anti-débordement ?
Premièrement, lorsque vous allez au supermarché,
n'y allez pas les mains vides,
vous prenez un caddie,
et ça, c'est hyper important.
À partir du moment où vous avez un caddie,
vous allez pouvoir mettre un pack d'eau dedans,
ou un pack de panaché.
de panaché  *ralenti*
Voilà pourquoi j'adore William,
comme moi, il boit pas d'alcool,
parce que c'est un homme responsable.
Mais en même temps, il aime bien le goût de la bière
PARCE QUE C'EST UN FOU DANS SA TÊTE !!
(musique de thug)
Attendez, attendez, pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut un caddie avec du panaché pour draguer ?
Ça, j'ai pas compris.
Auprès des filles que vous allez aborder dans le magasin,
ça fait que vous n'êtes pas un dragueur professionnel.
Mais c'est tellement intelligent, William !
Mais oui, ça, quand je parle aux filles, chaque fois, elles me disent :
''Ouais, j'ai peur que les hommes soient des dragueurs professionnels dans les magasins, comme ça.''
En plus, quand on voit William,
bah, séducteur, chemise de couleur vive qui attire les femmes, c'est sûr.
Attention, c'est pas le seul conseil, il y en a plein d'autres.
Ne vous approchez pas trop près de la fille.
Il faut garder à peu près, on va dire, 2 mètres.
C'est marrant, je trouve que ça fait un peu beaucoup moi.
On va vérifier, Romain, viens.
Viens, on va te mettre une perruque.
Alors, hop. Non, non.
Voilà.
Ça fait beaucoup, hein ?
C'est pas... c'est pas dingue, dingue
pour aborder les femmes.
C'est peut-être le jour où on n'a pas pris la douche.
Mais William va plus loin.
Il est dans le futur !
Faut-il draguer les caissières dans les magasins ?
Bah oui, nous, nous, le commun des mortels,
on pourrait croire que non.
Bah, les caissières, elles sont en train de travailler,
y a la queue, c'est stressant, c'est pas l'endroit, mais...
Hm-hm...
Pas pour William.
J'en ai fait pas mal. Des dizaines.
Et, à chaque fois que j'ai pu obtenir un numéro de téléphone d'une caissière,
soit c'était un faux numéro, soit elle ne me répondait pas.
Désolé, il me faut une seconde, là parce que...
(émotion)
Attendez, William qui s'est pris un râteau, putain.
Alors, comme le dit si bien William :
faites de la pratique, de la pratique, de la pratique.
William vous montre gratuitement la façon
dont il ramène ses nombreuses femmes séduisantes dans son lit
juste pour vous avec de la pratique.
(dans un magasin)
Ça a à peine commencé, vous avez déjà remarqué ?
La petite caméra miniature utilisée essentiellement
par les espions...
et les psychopathes.
Et on est dans son endroit de prédilection,
le supermarché, le caddie, le panaché,
le combo gagnant, il est comme un poisson dans l'eau.
-Bonjour je m'appelle William
je suis d'Arcachon, j'ai 32 ans
BOUH, la phrase d'accroche est tellement dingue
qu'elle en fait tomber son steak.
Moi je suis célibataire
Ouais mais pas moi.
pas vous ? D'accord bon.
William vient de se...
William vient de se prendre un rat... William vient de...
Je ne suis pas prêt. Je ne suis pas prêt.
Attendez, attendez, c'est... c'est forcément
l'exception qui confirme la règle.
Je, je le sais, c'est sûr, c'est sûr,
William, il pécho un maximum de filles.
D'ailleurs, il le prouve dans ses vidéos
-Bonjour je m'appelle William
Je suis d'Arcachon et je cherche une copine
Je travaille dans l'immobilier
Ah mais moi c'est déjà fait.
D'accord.
Je ne comprends pas, je ne comprends pas,
ce n'est pas possible, ce n'est pas possible.
En tout cas, j'aime beaucoup sa manière de flouter les visages,
avec un mot énorme, comme ça, sur la gueule.
William est aussi un petit peu expert dans l'art du montage.
Il y a forcément une vidéo sur sa chaîne où il chope un numéro.
C'est pas possible autrement.
-Je suis déjà pouvue de...
D'accord.
-Vous êtes pas mal...
Heu désolé je suis presser
Ah vous avez quelqu’un déjà
Je suis célibataire alors je me dis...
-Bah non désolé.
-Vous êtes déjà prisent ?
Ouais.
Attendez, attendez, parce que, je comprends pas,
là, j'avoue, je, je suis perdu,
ce serait la première chaîne de séduction,
où il y a que des râteaux, quoi.
À quoi ça sert ?
Je vous conseille d'acheter ce gilet pare-balle dernier cri,
arrête les balles à bout portant, la preuve.
*tire*
Je, regrette, je regrette beaucoup.
Je me suis dit : bien, tiens, j'ai envie de vous parler.
"Belles dents blanches".
Du coup, je suis curieux de savoir à quoi ressemblent
les filles qu'il drague d'habitude.
Hop, hop, hop hop, attendez, elle a pas encore dit non.
Elle a pas encore dit non.
YES, WILLIAM !!! OUI, C'EST ÇA, MON GARS !!!
PHRASE D'ACCROCHE, CADDIE, PANACHÉ !!
Alors... Alors, il s'est passé comment le rendez-vous?
C'était un faux numéro.
MAIS NON !! MAIS NON !!
NON, NON, NON !!
Bon, comme le dit William, coach en séduction,
dans la région de Bordeaux et d'Arcachon,
la théorie, c'est bien, la pratique, c'est mieux.
J'ai décidé de coucher avec des dizaines de jolies femmes
aux belles dents blanches, aujourd'hui.
Avec la méthode William.
C'est parti !
Mettez de belles chaussures de ville en cuir,
des beaux pantalons,
mettez de belles chemises jaunes.
Bonjour, je m'appelle William, j'ai 32 ans,
je réside à Arcachon.
Bonjour, je m'appelle William, j'ai 32 ans.
Hey, mais Cyprien?
Non, c'est William, mais...
J'habite à Arcachon.
Pardon ?
Je... Ah, oula, pas trop près, non, non.
Euh, là, là, c'est mieux.
Et t'es célibataire, sinon?
Ouais, je suis célibataire ouais.
Tu peux... me donner peut-être ton numéro ?
Ben ouais, pourquoi pas?
Moi, je me cherche une copine.
Non, merci.
Non, j'ai v... vous achetez des tampons?
Des tamp...
Attends, viens, on fait un snap.
Ça dure deux secondes...
T'habites dans le coin sinon?
Non, je... non, non. Je suis, de... d'Arcachon.
D'Arcachon... Voilà.
Super. Merci.
T'es célibataire sinon?
Euh non, mais on peut s'arranger..
J'attends de tes nouvelles.
Ça marche, salut Marie !
Je me cherche une copine, vous êtes jolie.
C'est gentil, mais non, merci.
Non, non, c'est...
Parce que je porte du jaune quand même.
C'est mieux donc, je disais, je me cherche une copine, je...
Là, c'est trop loin, là.
Hey, je suis pas un dragueur professionnel, j'ai du panaché, hein?
Ce que j'adore avec William, c'est qu'il est modeste.
À ce jour, il a renommé toutes ses vidéos sur sa chaîne youtube en
"La 1ère chaine de séduction humoristique".
Ça veut dire qu'il couche avec tellement de femmes chaque jour
que, bah, pour lui, ses conseils, c'est de la rigolade.
Alors si vous êtes déçus par la méthode William
pour des raisons... que j'ignore,
il faut savoir, sur Youtube,
il y a plein plein plein d'autres cons...
...coachs ! Coachs en séduction,
avec d'excellents conseils,
d'excellentes phrases d'approche.
Bonjour mademoiselle,
est-ce que je peux vous renseigner?
Ah oui, je cherche une petite robe de mariage...
En fait, c'était une blague, enfin,
je travaille pas ici, c'était juste une excuse
pour venir te voir.
Ah ah ah ah ! *rire forcé*
Abonne-toi.
Elle a pas aimé les dinosaures?
Non, non, elle a pas aimé, d'ailleurs,
elle a envoyé une météorite, il reste plus rien.
Quoi?
ET MON T-REX, ELLE A PAS GARDÉ MON T-REX ?